[Music]
all these stops on Chrissa mingle almost
what got just a single Kanye West isn't
afraid to address family drama the
rapper held a star-studded listening
party in Jackson Hole Wyoming Thursday
night to celebrate his new album yay
which is chock-full of candid lyrics
like this one about sister-in-law Khloe
Kardashian's beau Tristan Thompson who
allegedly cheated days before she gave
birth christening was what the singles
but Tristan isn't the only celebrity
that's name-checked
Kerry Washington that's gonna be an
enormous scandal I'm to have Nami
Campbell who still might want me a
stormy day the album also has darker
moments and I'm thinking about killing
myself and I love myself way more than I
love you so and even references Kanye's
most recent controversy when he faced
severe backlash for calling slavery a
choice
my wife Carla scream and say we bout to
lose it all had to calm it down cuz she
couldn't breathe told her she could
leave me now but she would
[Music]